centuries ago the people of salisbury
would have come to their cathedral to
pray for deliverance from the black
death now it's the vaccine that gives
them hope against a modern plague
local gps turned the transept into a
clinic with the aim of immunizing more
than a thousand
of the most vulnerable to covid any
nerves
soothed by music played on the
cathedral's famous organ
ada watkins is 90 but feels she's jumped
the cue
i think really and truly
i shouldn't have had it because i think
the young people ought to have it first
but i'm i'm doing as i'm told
but i really do feel guilty about it
in the rush to roll out the vaccine the
most improbable buildings are being used
is expected that seven more mass
vaccination hubs will open up next week
including bournemouth international
conference center
almost half of all those over 80 have
now had their jabs
for these doctors it may well be the
most important medical procedure of
their careers
we know that if we vaccinate 20 people
today
we're going to save likely save one life
which is remarkable
the number of people we're vaccinating
and therefore in theory the number of
lives that we're saving
is absolutely fantastic the nhs is
confident that it's on track with a
rollout
the first appointment letters for the
five and a half million over 70s
could be sent any day now there is no
evidence that any of the new variants of
the virus are resistant to the vaccines
but there is concern particularly about
the variant that has evolved in brazil
and scientists are keeping a close eye
on virus samples here in the uk
for any sign that it has already spread
this is how the kent variant spread
rapidly in just one month
starting in the southeast of england
then sweeping the country
it shows the danger of more
transmissible versions of the virus
this is a positive story for the uk in
the the lighthouses can
see the variant and they're looking out
to the horizon now to make sure
that as new variants arise we can see
those
two and track them effectively but there
are concerns that the vaccine
can't be made fast enough pfizer has
temporarily reduced deliveries while it
upgrades its production facilities to
meet
global demand the factory producing this
has a certain capacity and
obviously the world is screaming for
vaccine and they need to make changes in
the factory so that they get a higher
capacity it can get more
out but you can't sort of repair a car
while it's rolling you've got to stop it
do the work start it again and off you
go
the nhs does have the oxford jab and the
government says there is still plenty to
go around
doctors are injecting it as fast as they
can but rarely
in a more spectacular setting thomas
more sky news in salisbury